This beautiful tuck lace stitch pattern
is a very simple example
of what we can knit by combining
tuck and needles out of work.
It's created by putting needles out of
work on each side of the tuck stitches.
The Stitch World books and some vintage
publications may show the stitch pattern
in a diagram that looks like this.
But on the needle bed, how do you
know what needles to put out of work?
The easiest thing is to do a test run.
Use some scrap yarn and cast on enough
needles for a few repeats
of the stitch pattern.
Cast on over every needle
and knit a couple of rows.
Then engage your punch card or electronics
and set your machine to tuck.
Knit across all the needles
in tuck and observe what happens.
You can see which stitches
are being tucked.
With
this stitch pattern, needles are out of
work on each side of the tucked stitches.
You could transfer or empty these needles
and continue to test your stitch pattern
in your scrap yarn, or
just note which needles need to be out
of work when you cast
on with your garment yarn.
Using a test run ensures
that you put the correct needles
out of work according to your pattern.